[Music]  Taylor Swift and her rumored Bojo Alwyn  enjoy what else a cup of joe is sooo yep  here's the pair relaxing on a balcony in  Nashville getting their caffeine fix I  said I'm a cup of coffee right as in I  really need coffee the 27 year old  singer looked fresh-faced and kept it  casual in a fuchsia dress and dainty  necklace Joe was dressed pretty low-key  too opting for a simple t-shirt and  jeans  the duo first sparked dating rumors in  May and just last week they were  photographed together for the first time  getting on a private plane although they  boarded separately they both rocked  black hoodies twinning and winning our  Taylor and Joe heating up as a new  couple tweet us and let us know what you  think at ET now  [Music]  you